[Music]
today's a very special day of the
episode Ryan tell him why ah
today's episode is one where I eat this
ghost pepper candy because it's the
Halloween edition of learning and
burning I need that
Nate's gonna ask me a bunch of questions
and then I have to get them right before
I get to drink the glasses milk and we
do this why because the internet seems
to like before with a scotch bonnet yeah
we've done it with a habanero yeah yeah
we did it with a tube of wasabi one time
and then we did it without recording it
with the habanero just to see if it was
funny the first time with the ghost
pepper candy which has a Scoville rating
of between eight hundred and fifty five
thousand and one million twice as hot as
anything you've tried before
also we bought this from the internet
from a place that does not seem to be
FDA approved uh no tests we have no idea
how hot this is there's not even a
perforated edge on the package you have
to cut it open with scissors and you
can't read the ingredients because they
have like some weird label over it I
also try to watch a video of them
testing on a bunny the bunny has
exploded so this candy can explode a
bunny we're gonna put look if I die it's
for the good of this show the view camp
will go through the roof buddy man's
eyes on talk show trying to appease the
math people I think you're gonna die I
think worst-case scenario is late or
like does irreversible damage to your
tongue or something like you can never
enjoy food again worst case scenario
Ryan get to it let's open that up okay
so this is gonna be a fun little
unboxing yeah this will be switch so
what we have here is obviously the Ghost
Pepper candy is this in the shot I
specifically asked for blue raspberry
because I thought that that would be
maybe like
cooling sensation it's really hard and
it's like it seems to be like one piece
just like a thick unless it melted in
the beautiful Donna let's hear this so
now I'm gonna open it gonna screamed at
me this is an image of death what is it
say on the back you can't read it
because they put a package label that's
terrifying over the thing
it just says flamethrower and malic acid
whatever that is 80 calories this is a
lot Brian is getting nervous cuz the
package label is just a Barca okay he's
having trouble with the package I see
why on purpose no I'm not it's hard to
open oh we're in is there smell oh okay
there's like Chinese riding on this - it
definitely gonna be the baby
oh it melted at some point it's one
piece don't eat this do not eat this
part Neverland usually if you try this
at home do not eat the piece of plastic
it was on paper it actually tasted fine
that's LSD alright
can you see the chunks let me do my
segment chubby candy I've never seen
half an eat half of it is that
acceptable no no eat the whole alright
so we've broken off a hunk that seems to
be about one serving size of candy I
don't think that's right okay and you're
gonna have to keep that in your mouth
the entire time Ryan then I will give
you a card which will be on today's
topic which is Halloween you will have
to read about it learn about it and then
I will ask you a series of questions
only once you have answered all of them
correctly will you get the sweet relief
of this glass of milk do you understand
foot of that representative of the black
community I don't think should do this
but things gonna be very entertaining
now Chris speaks for all black people
and he says you think that he should not
do this oh no no in the black community
you were naughty this just so you know
can you see it looks like sawdust is I
think it looks like asbestos you're
being a baby
all right ready Ryan no please read the
card Oh Halloween Day the word home oh
thanks about 17 at 45 and is our
Christian origin
it means hallowed evening and it comes
from a Scottish trim for all house II
meaning the evening before all house day
all muscle notice All Saints say there's
a Christian festival celebrated in honor
of all the saints known and unknown
Saint Mark arias of Alexandria is good
candy makers in business I wonder if
Ryan we'd this is our rivalry just
anything I've written here googoo gaga
right
[Laughter]
Halloween costumes appeared in stores or
trading was becoming popular United
States's they said the tradition of
wearing the costume stems from trying to
trick the devil so you read through it
Oh first question initial thoughts how
does this compare to the habanero times
where the blue raspberry is kind of
cooling and then there are times where
this is going straight to my balls that
seem like you're getting a handjob
[Laughter]
question what is Halloween and what's
honest what is all holiday the Scoville
scale rates spiciness how many Scoville
units would you guess you're feeling
that ghost pepper candy right now
800,000 okay great Ryan what is st.
Macarius the patron saint oh I'm looking
for 313 ad that's one of them hey that's
the other costume
[Laughter]
candymakers is correct pastry chefs is
correct one others do either of you
remember can you help them out no it's
it was generic one for someone who makes
food oh I want another word next
question
wind and trick-or-treating first become
popular looking for a decade trick or
treating first become popular 1700 no so
far 92 money so close
ten the other way traditionally why do
people wear costumes last question Brian
have you ever made love while wearing a
costume
alright great job Brian that was the
ghost pepper candy challenge we're gonna
do something different right now Hannah
is gonna do a Halloween edition of
attention hacks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
happy Halloween bitches this hat makes
me look like an asshole but my producers
are making me wear it and honestly
that's kind of the whole bit because
this is attention hex why start a
conversation when you can be the
conversation these are tips I've seen
I've done you're welcome
one offer suggestions always offer
costume suggestions regardless of how
well you know someone not everyone can
be as creative and self-aware as you
it'd be a missed opportunity if you
didn't tell your PE teacher she looks
like Ursula or tell your coworker she
could totally fill in for Roseanne's to
guess the costume
if someone's costume was slightly
ambiguous play the guessing game it gets
the conversation going and lets them
know how you really think about them
Bojack horseman stormy Daniels oh you're
not wearing a costume you proved you're
the funny one
look it's not easy being the funny guy
at the water cooler especially with all
these new harassment laws Halloween is
perfect for moving outside your
co-workers comfort zones a fat suit ha
larious but just make sure you carry an
insulin pump otherwise people might not
get it and hey if you offend someone
just remind people you are fluent in
sarcasm and you have a ton of grafalk to
use to prove it besides this is why
Halloween was created to push boundaries
and also sell cocaine which brings me to
my next attention hat cocaine why do you
think they call a nose candy baby
personally I do not do cocaine I don't
know why I think it's just cause like my
parents are still married
however I've seen it do wonders for
people at corporate Halloween parties
it'll give you just enough confidence to
pitch a ton of business ideas to your
CEO and if you get a little too hot up
you can just blame it on all those mini
Twix
define your relationship couples
costumes are perfect for defining your
relationship with your significant other
my personal face outlet and plug lets
people know you've Danny and Sandy lets
people know you but also you might be
gay whatever you land on do what I do
and just make sure your partner is a
little bitch
finally this is Halloween the day to
scare the out of people
I always pop a pregnancy test box right
on top of the trash with my name written
in bold and Sharpie gets my name
circulating the office gets questions
stirring like is this why sheets to
lunches should she be drinking is that
why she's been walking with a limp every
office Halloween party ends with the
story and obviously you want it to be
about you and if you're down to the wire
and all else fails just do what every
celebrity does and appropriate some
culture that was very funny Chris you
got a shout out from a man Javier
Fernandez and this was in lieu of the
what's the ultimate Florida man style
story okay
Florida man desperate to find Keys burns
down house that's a good Florida man
story last night I bought a Snapple and
then I got home and it was gone I don't
know where what I bought a huge Snapple
had it in a bag I get home I still don't
I lost it so you think well I'm just
saying like I lose and like like
I'll go in the house to get a cold I'll
come out with a popsicle
right we have to film the show I feel
like that Florida man stories like a
case of a DD where I feel like I have a
DD which is just being a magician like I
just loose all the time and I cause
horrible Jana do you believe in
magic
a little yeah do you believe in witches
no I believe in like magic like the
years a lot done back there but we gotta
let this guy go recover thanks for
watching please like comment subscribe
and check us out on Twitter on extra
damn day where we talk about what's
trending online
[Music]